Yeah,
>> thank you for joining us today. So, the
longer form discussion this morning was
about stable coins. We've touched on
this in the past. The reason why stable
coins have come into existence is to
facilitate crypto and um all of the
so-called exchange activity around that
and it's essentially provided an onoff
ramp from ETH or Bitcoin and and all of
the plethora of crypto coins that have
come into existence or crypto tokens
rather. um to take their wins as it were
and move them back into fiat money that
they can spend in the real economy. um
what I've often accused crypto of being
a process of taking real money or sorry
fiat money from people um and then
washing it in this crypto mix and then
pulling it back out making the person
who put the money in poor but making the
person who created the so-called crypto
uh offering very rich indeed um whilst
they run the pump and dump scheme.
the the the emergence of of stable coins
from a perspective of institutional use
fails for me on a simple base that I've
never known an institution that would
accept that another institution would
get all of the yield on their debt
instrument which is what a a fiat money
dollar is. So it must be more about
facilitating what's happening in the
so-called crypto world and none of that
makes any sense. Now, as we were talking
through it this morning, one of the
points made toward the end of the
conversation that Craig made was that
when he thought all this through and
heard all the different points of
discussion that the team members had, he
wasn't sure whether stable coins
represented ammo or coffin nails. Craig,
what did you mean by that?
>> Yeah. So, like it's obvious that we're
getting we're being handed a bag. And I
say we like the the general crypto
landscape is being handed a bag. and
it's nice and heavy, but I can't tell if
it's ammo or coffin nails. And the
reason I'm saying that is ammo is
useful. You can do useful stuff with it.
Um, that's the whole point of having
ammo. Coffin nails on the other hand,
there seem to be so many
there seems to be a lot of potential for
massive crypto whales to absolutely
crush even on accident crush a new rel
new new and therefore small and
therefore relatively illquid
uh stable coin could just be totally
flattened by one of the crypto whales.
If that were to happen, well, you get
this potential for a cascade effect um
that Jarvis brought up, which is you can
spook people kind of quickly out of the
smaller. If you get one small stable
coin that spooks people because they had
a, you know, a liquidity crunch,
then people want to get out of the other
ones, too. And that could boil up to
something kind of wild pretty quickly in
the regulation. uh the um the Genius
Act, the Stable Genius Act. Um
there's some good points. One of them is
that it's saying these have to be backed
properly. Then there's this weird thing
where like they don't have to get
audited. I don't see how that's
useful. Um and then there's this other
point that um you know I was asking it
in the longer conversation about like
what's the actual difference here
between like an offering by that's just
a any database ledger system kind of
like what Visa does. What's the
difference between that and a stable
coin if the coins don't have any
technical specification to them which we
view as a positive thing the the
lawmakers the policy makers are not
trying to dictate technology that's
always a good thing. However, it raises
the question, what's the difference
between a stable coin that's a
cryptocurrency and just something in a
database? And UL was OL homeed in on
that like pretty quickly. So, like I
don't know, expand on that.
>> Yeah.
Typically, I guess I would expect a
stable coin to not actually be based on
a blockchain, but basically just be a
financial instrument that you can trade
for crypto in a crypto exchange, which
itself isn't regulated typically. And uh
um
when you are trading in the casino that
is a crypto exchange
uh that stuff doesn't touch a blockchain
unless they have an internal one but
typically it it can might as well just
be a database. So in that sense stable
coins are not likely to be
cryptocurrencies.
They're they're just essentially an
alias that will allow us to go between
different cryptocurrencies and from
cryptocurrencies to fiat. Uh but they're
not crypto per se.
At least they definitely don't have to
be. And if they don't have to be, then
why not Postgress? That's Postgress is a
very famous and very good
>> database management system. That's a
hell of a lot faster than running a
blockchain.
>> So when are these even token like when
is that gets into a fuzzy question
probably Jarvis knows more about this
but like when is it even the case that
a stable coin's representation is just
in someone's database ledger versus when
is it a token a tokenized asset that's
like actually on a chain somewhere?
Like what's the where are the dividing
lines?
Yeah, I mean um the intention here uh
you know hope this the spirit of the law
seems to be encouraging uh stable coins
as tokens on chains like Ethereum where
you can use them as a denomination for
smart contracts and um
uh it's a it's a
in a world where a lot of exchanges are
centralized exchanges that um distribute
coins as they uh
as they see fit. Um
some some proportion of which are on
chain, most of which is is in their
database. In fact, um you could well
have a a stable coin that is is launched
entirely on Binance. You can um trade
Bitcoin for this stable coin, trade it
back and redeem it on Bitcoin chain as
Bitcoin. Um
uh as for onchain stable coins, there
was uh some pretense of a use case there
for um being able to denominate smart
contracts in uh in US dollars instead of
in uh volatile
um volatile coins whose price could
change a lot in the lifetime of a smart
contract. Um the strange thing about
this regulation in trying to give more
regulatory backing to cryptocurrency
um and cryptocurrency in America is it
is giving regulatory support to one of
the least useful things you could do in
crypto which is make a second stable
coin. Um if stable coins were useful
USDT would have already solved to these
problems and made these things possible.
Um the the the fact that it hasn't
speaks to a recurring point here which
is that cryptocurrency as it has been
made so far is fundamentally not useful
and not able to solve the problems it
was intended to solve. Um the solution
there is not to launch more stable coins
but to create a chain that can actually
solve problems so that denominating a
dollar on it is useful at all. Um, which
leads me to, as uh Craig was alluding to
earlier, to speculate that uh if this is
to have any effect at all is to
reintroduce competition to uh to stable
coins. So that instead of being a single
monopoly that's acting essentially like
a bank issuing people a representation
of dollars as long as uh you give them
dollars to hold in some account
somewhere. Um once you get competition
between banks that people might withdraw
from one and deposit in another, um we
might quickly rediscover the world of
bank runs that exists
in a wild west without a a a central
system that we kind of accidentally have
with USDT. Um
and uh once people remember what bank
runs are are like that that could be the
the death of stable coins if anything
which would be a very ironic outcome for
this regulation.
>> So what you're touching on there is is
all about confidence and essentially the
whole crypto game is a confidence play.
It's that's the con. That's con is short
for confidence game. Um, and you're
right, if if some smaller uh
stable coins were to emerge and then get
crushed in liquidity exit, I mean, for
example, Ul talked about the the drop in
Bitcoin last week. um and there was a
sort of a movement out in
um what would happen to us a much
smaller uh stable coin and obviously it'
be crushed and and would that news then
ripple out into the market and and in an
industry that is entirely driven by
confidence and not by any realities what
does that do um
there's a lot of arguments being made
that this is about setting free
institutions
I I struggle with that and and actually
I'd like to invite anybody who would
like to say make that argument to come
and talk to us about it because the bit
that I just keep tripping up over like a
a twoft uh doors stop as you walk
through a door is but I've never come
across an institution that would let you
have 4% yield on their debt instrument
their fiat money
and just say yeah that's fine the the
point that I find somewhat alarming is
that anybody sees that having access to
a stable coin is worth giving that up
because it's feeding into an industry
that is a great big
confidence game. You know, it's all
number go up. There's no real value
being built on these so-called meme
coins or any of these things.
So
in that context,
what is happening here that makes this
worthwhile and and you know the point
was raised and made correctly that a bit
like ETFs, this is about expediting the
process of bringing in as many bag
holders as possible because the easier
you make it for people to get into this
crypto nonsense, the easier it is to
fleece them of their money. And the
second part is that it also makes it
much easier to offload if you're one of
the whales. Um, you know, the comment
was made by the anti-Trump New York
Times that he had made a huge amount of
money out of his uh his meme token, but
it failed to grasp the point that that's
only true if he could exit at today's
price. If the Trump family were to exit
immediately, the whole thing would just
collapse. And to that extent, it's a bit
of a Ponzi scheme, but all of crypto is.
So
I think the question what we finished
our long form discussion was with was
that there were far more questions that
this generated than answers that it
gave. And you know that's before we get
into any of the things about how we're
splitting apart the the onant cordial
between the statists who've had the
license to print money and the
corporists who've had the license to tax
us for all of our economic endeavor with
that money. Um it's going to be an
interesting time. I think, you know,
Bitcoin was supposed to light the way
for creating a non-debaseable onchain
currency that um self-referential, which
means it doesn't get reference to how
many dollars it buys you, but rather how
many eggs it buys you, how many um
pens it buys you. self-referential
meaning that much as somebody who gets
on the tube in London doesn't try to pay
in dollars they pay in pounds and they
don't then try and think oh well you
know it's £150 to go from here to the
next stop that's actually 24
nobody does that um
so
the the questions coming around stable
coins and this huge influx of money into
them at the same time that
nobody really took the proof of concept
of Bitcoin and turned it into something
that really worked. I mean, Litecoin
tried different aspects of it. BSV have
tried different aspects of it, but
they've ultimately run into
a litany of issues that make it very
hard for them to emerge beyond their
beginnings. We've done something from
scratch with the Gaju. It's the only
open global currency that delivers the
vision that was originally proposed in
the Bitcoin white paper, a peer-to-peer
electronic cash system. The Gaju is a
peer-to-peer electronic cash system for
the interplanetary human species and the
next 5,000 years. And with that, thank
you.